[Musique]
excusez-moi meilleur mois depuis le
début de l'émission je suis horrifié les
autres monsieur bédié qui nous promet
qu'il va tenir ses promesses
on est très content un bon il souffre
beaucoup monsieur mélenchon notamment un
des critiques qui sont faites aux
politiques et pourtant qu'est ce que
vous les méritez un parce que qui a
contribué à faire croire aux français
que l'intégralité des hommes politiques
étaient malhonnêtes
c'est vous et c'est vous parce que vous
parce que moi parce que mais oui bien
sûr - artix mais qui à lui seul la
caisse claire l'udf et le pc vous voulez
que je vous rappelle à cet homme
d'affaires
parce que monsieur alpha ne le fera plus
il a oublié lui les affaires il a oublié
la lutte contre la corruption puisqu'il
a voté pour le premier de la gamme
france alors la langue de bois
et bien c'est son la langue de bois non
attendez un peu et construire la
démocratie je me rendais l'avez sûrement
pas parisien leonardo et non pas de
rabat dont marine le pen
monsieur marine le pen marine le pen
pardon je le dis à tous pour esi la
sorefi 15 janvier pour éviter en tout
cas que ce débat puisse ressembler à
certains autres qui ont été très
critiqués je vous demande un peu de
dignité de décès nous a enlevé le doigt
qui part dieu qui m'a sud à lorient et
vous assure toi j'ai à dire fait sa
nouvelle je le dis à vous comme aux
autres un peu de calme
[Musique]